>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY.
MY FAVORITE THURSDAY BUDDIES.
IT'S A VERY, VERY SPECIAL NIGHT
TONIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S TIME FOR...
♪ ♪
>> THE GUTFELD AWARDS.
>> Greg: THE VERY FIRST
GUTFELD INTERNATIONAL FEMINIST
AWARD.
UNLIKE THE OSCARS, WE ARE GOING
TO KEEP IT SHORT.
TONIGHT WE HAVE ONE WINNER.
DO YOU KNOW WHO THAT IS?
THE FIRST GUTFELD INTERNATIONAL
FEMINIST AWARD GOES TO...
THIS IS SO EMBARRASSING.
I HAD NO IDEA.
SUCH A SURPRISE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO TO THINK AT
THIS POINT AND I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING PREPARED TO SAY EXCEPT
FOR THE MONOLOGUE WHICH I WROTE
SO I COULD GIVE MYSELF AN AWARD.
I NEVER WOULD MAKE ANYTHING.
I NEVER THOUGHT OF MYSELF AS A
FEMINIST PROBABLY BECAUSE I
COULD NEVER GROW A MUSTACHE.
>> A SEXIST WOULD SAY...
>> Greg: THAT'S TERRIBLE.
YOU SHOULDN'T LAUGH.
HOW COULD I BE A FEMINIST?
I ADMIRE CHIVALRY.
I AM NOT ANGRY.
I'VE YET TO BURN A BRA.
NOT INTENTIONALLY.
IN THIS CRAZY TIME IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S TIME FOR SOMEONE TO TAKE
THE LEAD DEFENDING WOMEN SINCE
THE FEMINIST GROUPS HAVE GONE
AWOL.
LADIES, FOLLOW ME.
IF I DON'T ASK FOR DIRECTIONS
ALONG THE WAY THAT'S HOW DUDES
ROLL.
SO ALLOW ME TO MAN-'S PLANE.
THERE IS NOT SO MUCH A WAR ON
WOMEN IT'S LIKE A PERSISTENT
EROSION.
IT'S CREEPING INTO SCIENCE,
LANGUAGE, COURT ROOMS, RESTROOM
SPORTS INDUSTRY.
YOU KNOW IT'S A PROBLEM WHEN
LEADING FEMALE ACHIEVERS CAN NO
LONGER TELL YOU WHAT A WOMAN OR
A MAN IS.
>> CAN YOU PROVIDE A DEFINITION
FOR THE WORD WOMAN?
>> CAN I PROVIDE A DEFINITION?
YEAH.
I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN'T?
>> NOT IN THIS CONTEXT.
I'M NOT A BIOLOGIST.
>> PEOPLE WITH THE CAPACITY FOR
PREGNANCY.
WITH EFFIE WOMEN?
WOULD THAT BE WOMEN?
>> MANY SYS WOMEN HAVE THE
CAPACITY FOR PREGNANCY.
MANY DO NOT.
THERE ARE TRANS MEN CAPABLE OF
PREGNANCY AND NONBINARY PEOPLE.
>> YOUR VIEW IS THE CORE OF THIS
IS ABOUT WHAT?
>> I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE LINE
OF OF QUESTIONING IS TRANSPHOBIC
AND IT OPENS UP TRANS PEOPLE TO
VIOLENCE.
>> I WAS HOPING YOU COULD DEFINE
WHAT A WOMAN IS IN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
>> I'M A WOMAN.
THAT'S HOW IDENTIFY.
BUT I WONDER IF IN PART THE
REASON YOU'RE ASKING THE
QUESTION IS YOU ARE TRYING TO
SUGGEST PEOPLE --
>> I AM SIMPLY ASKING THE
QUESTION EVASIVELY WANT AN
ANSWER.
>> Greg: AS WE SAY AROUND THE
GYNECOLOGIST OFFICE, AIN'T THAT
A KICK IN THE NUTS?
THESE ARE QUESTIONS ANYONE COULD
ANSWER THREE OR TWO YEARS AGO.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS TWO OR
3-YEAR-OLD COULD ANSWER.
SCIENCE IS SECONDARY TO
POLITICS.
NO LONGER ABOUT BIOLOGY.
IT'S ABOUT INVENTING A LANGUAGE.
THE FAR LEFT VERSION OF PIG
LATIN.
WHO CONTROLS THE LANGUAGE
CONTROLS THE BODY.
ACCORDING TO OUR MOST PROMINENT
LEGAL MINDS A MAN CAN BE A
WOMAN.
A MAN CAN DO ANYTHING A WOMAN
CAN DO.
A FEW YEARS AGO IF A GUY SAID
THAT HE WOULD BE PELTED WITH
EGGS.
NOW APPARENTLY HE'S CAPABLE OF
PRODUCING THEM.
IF YOU DISAGREE, YOU ARE
FOMENTING HYPOTHETICAL VIOLENCE
AS REAL VIOLENCE PAYS A VISIT TO
BIOLOGICAL WOMEN.
>> THIS HOMELESS MAN RAN UP.
HE HAD SOMETHING IN HIS HAND.
HE LOOKED AT ME WITH SOME
HATEFUL EYES AND AS I TURNED, I
THINK SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH
HIM.
BEFORE I KNEW IT, A BIG METAL
BOLT, PIPE HIT ME.
>> Greg: FOR THE PAST YEAR WE
SAW WOMEN ATTACKED BY A DERANGED
MAN.
HITTING THEM WITH PIPES, PUSHING
THEM DOWNSTAIRS, PUSHING THEM IN
FRONT OF SUBWAYS.
NO FEMINIST GROUPS PIPE UP.
I WOULD SAY THAT THEY HAVE NO
BALLS BUT IN ALL HONESTY,
HAVEN'T CHECKED.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
I GUESS IT'S BETTER TO EXCUSED
DERANGED MALE FELONS THEN SIDE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ABUSERS WALK IN AND OUT BEFORE
THE BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS IS DRY
AND SOME REVISIT THEIR PREVIOUS
FEMALE VICTIMS WHICH IS IGNORED
BY PROGRESSIVE LOONS LIKE THE
L.A. D.A. GEORGE GASCON.
THAT MEANS WHEN YOU'RE RAPIST IS
UP FOR PAROLE YOU MIGHT BE THE
LAST PERSON TO KNOW.
WHERE ARE THE FEMINISTS?
THEY REFUSED TO TAKE THE FIELD.
SPEAKING OF, THE WHITE HOUSE
JUST ANNOUNCED NEW TITLE IX
RULES WHICH WOULD SWEEP GENDER
IDENTITY INTO THE LAW'S AND
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE
WHO FACE DETERMINATION BASED ON
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY.
WHO IS THIS MEANT TO PROTECT?
TAKE A GUESS.
>> I FIND IT FUNNY.
THAT IS WHAT I'M GETTING TEED UP
ABOVE THE MOST.
YOU ARE BEATING LITTLE GIRLS.
I DIDN'T INTEND TO DO THAT.
THIS WAS THE FIRST COMPETITION
THAT I HAVE BEEN TO THAT I
ACTUALLY WANTED TO WIN.
NOT GOING TO GO THERE AND BE
LIKE, GO EASY ON THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE KIDS.
>> TRY TO FOCUS ON MY SWIMMING,
WHAT I NEED TO DO TO GET READY
FOR MY RACES AND I TRY TO BLOCK
OUT EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> Greg: OF COURSE WHEN FEMALE
ATHLETES COMPLAINED ABOUT LOSING
THEIR SPOT TO SOMEONE WEARING A
JOCKSTRAP AND HAS A LUNG
CAPACITY OF A BLUE WHALE, THEY
ARE CALLED TRANSPHOBIC.
ENJOY YOUR SECOND, THIRD, FOURTH
PLACE TROPHIES, GIRLS.
NEVER MIND THAT WHEN SHE
COMPETED ON THE MEN'S TEAM SHE
WAS THE 505TH COMPETITOR.
NOW SHE'S IN THE TOP TEN.
IT'S FUNNY HOW THIS ONLY
BENEFITS MALE TO FEMALE TRANS,
NOT A LOT OF FEMALES WHO BECAME
MALES ARE WINNING IN SPORTS
WHICH MAY BE ANOTHER FORM OF
SEXISM.
AGAIN, WHERE ARE THE FEMINIST
GROUPS?
ARE THEY OKAY WITH GIRL ATHLETES
GETTING CRUSHED BY ATHLETES WITH
A PENIS AND MUSCLE DENSITY OF A
PIT BULL?
ONE ATHLETE WHO GOT A MEDAL OF
HONOR SAYS IF IT BOTHERS YOU TO
LOSE TO A TRANS WOMAN YOU SHOULD
SKIP SPORTS.
SPOKEN LIKE AN ATHLETE WHO IS
USED TO LOSING TO MALES.
HER TEAM GOT SHELLACKED BY
50-YEAR-OLD HIGH SCHOOL BOYS.
WHERE DO YOU TURN IF YOU'RE A
GIRL WHO IDENTIFIES AS A GIRL
WHO WANTS TO PLAY AGAINST OTHER
GIRLS.
DON'T EXPECT RAPINOE TO SAVE YOU
A SEAT ON THE BENCH.
IT IS SAD TO WATCH STRONG WOMEN
DO NOTHING TO STOP THIS STAND
WHILE MEN LIKE ME DO EVERYTHING.
I COULD GO ON AND ON BUT REALLY
THAT IS SOMETHING A WOMAN WOULD
DO.
AM I RIGHT?
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
IT'S NOT JUST HIS ACCENT.
HE REALLY IS SMARTER THAN YOU.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR DOUGLAS
MURRAY.
SHE IS SO SMART HER I.Q. COMES
WITH.
DEPUTY OPINION EDITOR AT
"NEWSWEEK" AND AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK.
BATYA UNGAR-SARGON.
SHE IS LIKE CLOROX WIPES.
99% ALCOHOL.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
HE TOLD THE BIG AND TALL STORE
TO GET BIGGER AND TALLER.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE
N.W.A. CHAMPION, TIRES.
TYRUS.
BATYA.
I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST BECAUSE
YOU ARE A FEMALE.
BY CHOICE OR BIOLOGY?
>> GOD MAY BE THAT WAY SO I'M
KIND OF STUCK WITH IT.
>> Greg: DOESN'T MATTER
ANYMORE.
WE CAN CHANGE IT.
I HAVE A ROOM.
THERE IS A DEPOT AROUND THE
CORNER.
DO YOU FEEL WOMEN ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
HAVE I PUT TOGETHER A PERSUASIVE
ARGUMENT?
>> THIS IS WHAT I THINK HAPPENS.
FOR A LONG TIME AND I'M VERY
CURIOUS WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS.
I AM COMING FROM THE LEFT.
I THINK FOR A LONG TIME THE LEFT
WAS AT THE FOREFRONT OF VERY
IMPORTANT CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUES
LIKE GAY RIGHTS, EQUALITY FOR
WOMEN, EQUALITY FOR BLACK
AMERICANS.
A LOT OF REALLY IMPORTANT
STRUGGLES.
THE LEFT WAS ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THOSE, PUSHING THEM FORWARD.
THE THING THAT HAPPENED RECENTLY
AS THEY WON.
THEY WON ON ALL THOSE FRONTS.
THERE IS NO LONGER A PARTISAN
DIVIDE ON ANY OF THOSE ISSUES.
SO THAT BECAME A PROBLEM FOR THE
LEFT BECAUSE YOU CAN NO LONGER
GO TO YOUR DINNER PARTY AND WIN
BY SAYING I DON'T THINK COPS
SHOULD BE BEATING UP BLACK
PEOPLE OR I THINK WOMEN SHOULD
BE TREATED EQUALLY IN THE
WORKPLACE BECAUSE EVEN
REPUBLICANS THINK THAT.
SO THEY NEEDED TO PUSH THE
GOALPOST AND WHAT THEY DID WAS
THEY PUSHED IT TO A PLACE THAT'S
JUST TOTALLY COUNTERINTUITIVE
WHERE IT'S ABOUT DR. KING'S
VISION IT'S CONSIDERED RACIST.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SAY THAT
WOMEN DESERVE EQUAL RIGHTS.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THERE'S NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN.
THEY HAD TO MOVE THE GOALPOSTS
OF THIS PLACE WHERE IT'S
ALIENATING LEFTIES LIKE ME.
>> Greg: WELL PUT.
IN DOUGLAS, IN ENGLAND THERE'S A
LOT OF HISTORY OF GENDER
CONFUSION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HOW LONG WERE YOU THEREFORE?
>> Greg: NOT LONG ENOUGH, I'M
AFRAID.
DO YOU FEEL THIS IS MORE ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE RUN INTO
THIS BRICK WALL OF SCIENCE.
SCIENCES KEEPING THEM FROM
ACHIEVING THIS SO THEY HAVE TO
REMAKE THE LINGUISTICS.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO GET AROUND
SCIENCE.
IT'S NEVER A GREAT THING TO TRY
TO GET AROUND.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET AROUND
FACTS AS WELL.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A PROBLEM AT
SOME POINT.
I'M NOT COMING FROM THE LEFT OF
COURSE.
I CAN SAY WITH SOME CONFIDENCE
ONE OF THE GREAT PLEASURES OF
OUR TIME IS SEEING THIS SNAKE
EAT ITS OWN TAIL.
THIS WEEK APART FROM THAT, THE
WEIRD BERKELEY PROFESSOR.
TALKING TO SENATOR HAWLEY.
SHE SAID NONBINARY PEOPLE CAN BE
PREGNANT.
IF THEY ARE WOMEN.
TRANS MEN CAN ALSO BECOME
PREGNANT, IF THERE WOMEN.
OF COURSE WOMEN.
SINCE WOMEN CAN BECOME PREGNANT.
BUT ALSO THIS WEEK WE SAW
RASHIDA TLAIB, THE BRILLIANT
CONGRESSWOMAN, MAKE A REALLY
IMPORTANT INTERVENTION.
SHE SAID THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS KILLING
TRANS PEOPLE AND SHOULD STOP
SAYING ANYTHING.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ACCIDENTALLY AB RAN ONE STORY A
LITTLE WHILE AGO LOOKING
HONESTLY AT THE TRANSITION.
THE CONGRESSWOMAN WAS LIKE NO,
WE'VE GOT TO STOP IT.
"NEW YORK TIMES," YOU'RE KILLING
PEOPLE.
I SIT BACK AND WATCH AND THINK
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS BECOME
A TRANSPHOBIC GREG, THIS THING
MUST BE NEARING A CONCLUSION.
"NEW YORK TIMES" HAS BECOME A
TRANS TRANSPHOBIC RAG.
>> Greg: KAT, I CONSIDER YOU A
FEMINIST.
>> I DON'T HATE MYSELF.
I DON'T HATE MYSELF BECAUSE I'M
A WOMAN.
I HATE MYSELF FOR OTHER REASONS.
>> Greg: I'M CURIOUS ABOUT
PREGNANT MAN.
WHO IMPREGNATES THEM?
>> WASN'T ME.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING ME ON THAT
ONE.
>> IT'S OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND.
WELL THE PENIS HAVERS.
I'M NOT CANCELED.
YOU SAY SOMETHING REASONABLE
LIKE THE PENIS HAVER IMPREGNATES
THE UTERUS HAVER.
>> Greg: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU SAY.
THAT'S FANTASTIC.
>> I SURE AM.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I AM MOST FEEL LIKE
SHARING MY AWARD WITH YOU.
>> THEY WILL NEVER LET ME SHARE
THESE THINGS ON "FOX & FRIENDS."
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: TYRUS, LAST WORD.
AS AN ATHLETE COME AS A
WRESTLER, HAVE YOU EVER
CONSIDERED WRESTLING WITH
CHILDREN JUST TO WIN?
LIKE THE MALE TO FEMALE
SKATEBOARDER WHO HAS ALL HIS
STUFF INTACT AND IS STILL
BEATING UP SKATEBOARDERS.
>> I'VE BEEN PRETTY SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE MOST OF THE GROWN ADULTS
I GET IN THE RING WITH LOOK LIKE
CHILDREN AGAINST ME.
I HAVE TO PUNCH DOWN.
REGARDLESS OF THIS INDIVIDUAL'S
PERCEPTION OF THEMSELVES OR WHO
THEY IDENTIFY, YOU ARE AN ADULT
AND YOU'RE COMPETING AGAINST
ADOLESCENT GIRLS.
NO ONE INTERVIEWED THEM.
I'M ASSUMING IT'S GIRLS.
NOT ONLY DID YOU BEAT THEM
SOUNDLY, YOU BRING ABOUT IT.
AND TOOK THEIR MONEY.
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THAT AS YOU
AND AN INDIVIDUAL.
EVEN IF THERE WAS A TOURNAMENT
TOMORROW.
THE SUPER WORLD WRESTLING
CHAMPIONSHIP OF THE UNIVERSE.
I STEPPED ACROSS THE RING AND
THERE WAS A TODDLER ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
HE'S GOING TO WIN THAT NIGHT.
I'M NOT GOING TO WRESTLE HIM.
THERE IS AN HONOR THAT.
WE LIVE IN A TIME WHERE IT'S
ABOUT ME.
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
GROUPS OR ANYTHING.
IT'S ME AND EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW
ME I'M SPECIAL ON THEM DIFFERENT
AND EVERYTHING IS DONE BY
FEELING SO YOU CAN'T ARGUE
FEELINGS.
SHE FELT LIKE SHE SHOULD WIN SO
WE SHOULD ALL UNDERSTAND.
>> Greg: AND IF YOU DISAGREE
WITH ME, YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CREATING A CLIMATE OF VIOLENCE.
YOU COULD KILL ME.
>> THAT IS WOKE FOR YOU HURT MY
FEELINGS.
>> Greg: WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY FOR T